hi
my name is isabel yepez i am an
electronics engineer
and i also act as a co-director of the
women who code network in bogota
i'm going to present a short discussion
about
natural language processing in spanish
and all the challenges that faces in
this
subject the idea of this presentation
is to show some of the challenges that a
one faces when it tries to develop
natural language processing
in spanish when the original language of
the content is
spanish and the alternatives that are in
the moment
to solve those challenges first
i want to talk about what it is
important to do
another language processing in spanish
one of the things is the amount of
people that
is actually creating content in spanish
this is the way of the a large amount of
population
of the world that actually speaks
spanish
is about 572 million of people
worldwide and including people who
speak spanish as a second language
spanish is the third language most used
in the internet
behind english and chinese and the
second most used language
in social network like facebook and
twitter
so there's a lot of content and there's
a lot of things that
it's important to investigate and
important to show how it behaves
from the things that people are actually
created
showing in numbers in the whole
continent including north america
and south america you can see the
distribution
of uh people using the internet
for country being the the most
used in argentina uh
the second country with more usual
bolivia chile and the fourth
one is colombia and you can see
the amount of users on facebook
accounted this year that in total in
only the whole continent north america
central america and south america
a 200 million of people
um that is participating in facebook
in an active form and the users
internet users counted to june of 2020
is
at 385
million so this is a large amount of
people that is creating content and is
participating and is important to
process it is important to um
to discuss how to analyze this data
because there are a lot of information
that is being created
and probably is not being treated in the
best way
it should be things you have
when you do nlp in english
that you don't have in spanish is that
you already have
libraries like this that have pertaining
classification for sentiment analysis
for example
there are common corpus included with
libraries
so when you do some analysis based in a
common library that use a common corpus
you can replicate the results in another
set of data
but it's not the same in spanish
you have lots of documentation of case
uses
about an end an early p in english
and there are uh many public available
corporates that are created and and easy
to
access uh free on the internet
one of the solutions that are proposed
to do this
processing is using translation
uh there are libraries that actually do
a good word like google trends
and just like api however
um those libraries are
developed by big companies they are not
open source more of them
you know that there's also the risk
meaning because
translation is not exactly precise
and translation faces certain challenges
by itself
like expressions and idioms words with
multiple
meanings and also sarcasm as a
difficulty
to uh do the translation approach
so when you try to do it in spanish
what do you need to do different that
because you don't have those things you
have for granted in english
first you have to find data sets to know
to load in these known libraries like
spacey
in order to make classifiers and
make training for example in sentiment
analysis you have the library that can
do the job but you
also need a trained
corpus to use the variety of corpus
come from universities and research
group and
the thing is there's no common corpus
use
widely used basically each person tries
to
use their own data or the data that is
given by the university that the person
belongs to
so when you try to replicate those
results and it's not necessary
the the same data or the same results
you you receive
there are not a social large a amount of
documentation
and much of the corpus belong to
universities
that have restrictions for distribution
uh because they were created
with not exactly creative commons
licenses and things like that
so the distribution distribution is not
necessarily open
what is the origin on of all those
things
most of the research is done by
universities
and results are mostly available for the
academic elite it's not something that
you publish open source
it's not something that you find freely
available
on github things like that you can find
libraries
but not necessarily corpus because
corpus belong to the research
groups so they are not available all the
time
the development of nlp in spanish
the well done research and and also the
preteenage technology
it belongs to uh private corporations
uh like microsoft that has their own
data and algorithms to trade spanish
grammar
the api is developed by google and aws
so um when they give you access to these
utilities they are black boxes you can't
interact with them inside and there are
not
much state communities producing results
available to general public and spanish
there are many communities but
most of them are focused on english not
in spanish
one can do uh in a better way
one is communicate about uh the
well developed efforts uh things that
are going are being doing good
by universities i'm going to to share
with you one example
um create a community of python that
is focused on nlp in spanish that can be
a subset of the already existing
community of
nlp but it's important to
start to focus on these and these issues
um the other thing is that one of the
reasons to
do this short and discussion
is to open uh for the attendance
if they have suggestions or proposals uh
about this and the resolution of this
kind of issues
and a personal question is how could you
contribute
to this solution i want to show you
uh one of the possibilities
that without good a
development and is uh
the sepla
that is a a community a spanish society
dedicated to another language processing
and they have collected a good
group of corpuses they have them
available but not freely you have to
register in order to download them
and you can realize something that is
not
something that is universal for example
this is
the data set for spain this is for costa
rica this is for peru
this is for uruguay and this is for
mexico
and the reason for this is that the
language is not the same and the words
not necessarily mean the same
depending on the country so this is
something that needs to be
also shackled that this is a good
advance that is being done but
it's not they put this for some
workshops
they do yearly and they put them
available
but this corpus can be used widely
probably because the information from
the corpus
comes from twitter and probably is not
available because of that
but this is a good effort and they do
they publish
they have a publication they have
congresses investigation
research uh training and so on
this is one of the things that could be
wider because
this depends more on universities is not
something like widely open to all people
however i think i
reach my objective that is putting this
and
to knowledge of the people so you can
process and make suggestions about this
there's my contact in the presentation
thank you
so much for attending this discussion
you